one of those people who's making moves
and is pretty bold
the fake ramaswamy you know I like the
guy he's a friend of mine of some years
and there's one thing that I don't like
about the fake there's one thing and I
listen friends have spats and I'm
willing to
come out with this one I
hated the rapping you know at the Iowa
State Fair he was rapping he did a rap
of Eminem Who I really can't stand I
don't like his music at all and he did
it and I know it worked and I know that
people got a kick out of it and it's
probably an effective campaign tactic
but I just
it drove me crazy and it drove Eminem
crazy too so Eminem has just come out
and demanded that Vivek stopped rapping
his music now this happens every cycle
anytime any candidate gets attention
and a candidate plays any popular song
at his rallies or his campaign stops
then the artist who 99 out of 100 times
his big lib comes out and makes a Big
Splash in the headlines you need to stop
using my song You're illegally playing
my song
look at your rally and it's so dumb and
it's such a Shameless Ploy for attention
but usually they have a point usually
they can say you're playing an
unlicensed version of my song
what's amazing about Vivek shows you
that he's a graduate of the number one
Law School in the country is he
he apparently got the licenses so so
what Eminem came at and he couldn't
demand that Vivek stop rapping you know
you would think that this little rapping
type thing was just a spur of the moment
thing and maybe it was the first time
but then because Vivek is a very sharp
lawyer and a very shrewd politician even
though he's never run for anything
before
he apparently went out and got the
license so so that he could stop exactly
what Eminem is trying to do right now so
Eminem even more impotently than the
musical artists usually have to do he
comes out and he says
hey I demand that BMI who holds the
catalog I demand that BMI revoke the
license that Vivek apparently has on my
song because I don't I don't want it I
don't want it to happen
so BMI sent a letter to Vivek says this
letter serves as notice that Eminem
works are excluded from the agreement
effective immediately
BMI will consider any performance of the
m m works by the Vivek 2024 campaign
from the state forward to be a material
breach of the agreement for which BMI
reserves All rights and remedies with
respect here too so I don't legally I
don't know if they can actually do that
if they can say hold on we're taking it
out of the agreement you don't get to do
Eminem anymore
but regardless now now I have to
flip-flop because I I don't like
Eminem's alleged music and I don't like
I don't like it when serious people rap
but the vague should be wrapping at
every campaign stop now this is so funny
this is such a great way to show not
only are the conservatives bold and
courageous and willing to mix things up
and everything but that also we
sometimes can outsmart the lips too and
get those licenses right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
I don't know about you but this summer
heat in Nashville feels hotter than a
two dollar pistol and thanks to
inflation everyone's feeling the heat in
more ways than one one thing that you
will not sweat this summer and this fall
and this winter
is the price of your meat thanks to good
ranchers my price is locked in for two
years yours can be too price lock
guarantee on me yes it's amazing I don't
get how their finances work to to allow
this to happen but it's incredible and
the the meat quality is also incredible
when I was a wheel ad steak was a very
rare special occasion kind of thing and
now good ranchers will bring you
extraordinarily high quality steak at an
extremely reasonable price to your door
to say nothing of all the other great
food they've got the chicken and the
pork and the burgers which I had last
night which are the best I've ever had
go to goodranchors.com use code
knowlescanderws for 30 bucks off any box
this promo code Knowles kwles
goodranchers.com goodranchers.com
American Meat delivered now Chris
Christie is lobbing more attacks at
Donald Trump and this attack actually
ties into our whole broad theme of the
day this attack is that Donald Trump
wants to be an authoritarian leader I
think what we have is a Donald Trump
problem and that right now what's gone
on is that people view Donald Trump
synonymously with the Republican party
and that if you oppose Trump that's
somehow favoring Biden and many
Republicans don't want to do that for
very obvious reasons
um and I think that that's why we need
to have this full debate and discussion
that we just really started on Wednesday
night about who should be leading our
party and who should be leading our
country and I've said very clearly on
the authoritarian side of things this is
Donald Trump's problem not the
Republican party's problem he's the guy
who thinks that uh Vladimir Putin's an
excellent leader and Brilliant he's the
guy who thinks that President XI is
straight out of Hollywood he's the guy
who thinks Kim Jong-un is wonderful I
mean these are things that he has said
about these authoritarian leaders and
it's because Donald Trump would like to
be one himself he wants to be an
authoritarian so
Christy bases his cheap shot on cheaper
shots which is Donald Trump has pointed
out that Xi Jinping is a apparently a
pretty competent leader of his country
which is just indisputably true
he's able to hold and exercise power
pretty effectively in China in a very
large country that's impressive
he's able to
build up his nation's economy and
maintain social order that's impressive
I'm not saying he's a good guy not
saying I agree with him that's not what
Donald Trump is saying either
same thing about Putin you think about
after communism after the collapse of
the Russian form of government you had
this failed guy Boris Yeltsin who had
all sorts of personal problems who
wasn't able to maintain her wield power
opened up his country to a lot of
corruption and then Vladimir Putin comes
in he has been able to maintain power
pretty effectively and he's remained
very popular among the Russian people so
you're not saying he's a good guy if you
if you point out that this is an
effective leader which is obviously what
Trump was doing here but Christine needs
those cheap shots those disingenuous
attacks to build up his broader point
which is that Donald Trump
he loves authoritarian he's an
authoritarian the conservatives are not
but he is
okay
Donald Trump waived an LGBT flag on the
campaign Trail in 2016. okay Donald
Trump is in no way an authoritarian
leader unless we're defining
authoritarian leader as
liberal from seven years ago
overstating this too much Donald Trump
speaks and acts in a rather liberal Way
by historical standards because he's
slightly more traditional and
conservative than I don't know Barack
Obama or something like that now
according to the squishes and the
Liberals he's an authoritarian he's the
second coming of Francisco Franco but
it's completely ridiculous but let's go
with Christy for a second let's say
Christy we're right let's say Donald
Trump really were an authoritarian let's
say that having men go into the men's
bathroom constitutes authoritarianism
for instance
what's the alternative to that
the alternative to supposed conservative
authoritarianism is liberal
totalitarianism but make no mistake
liberalism is totalitarian
and what's the distinction between the
two authoritarianism is when the
government says hey don't do stuff in
the streets that's crazy and weird don't
don't don't just follow whatever impulse
you've got in your appetites and parade
around on the street wearing leather
costumes smacking each other around
maybe don't do that okay
that's like that's what we're calling
authoritarian these days but like for
instance the Liberals called Victor
Orban in Hungary authoritarians
completely ridiculous but even if he
were what are they saying as
authoritarian is he goes out and he says
hey we're a Christian country you can
believe however you want to believe you
can engage in basically whatever
practices you want to engage in
in the privacy of your own home but in
public we're going to be a Christian
country and have Christian morality
that's all he said that's that's what
they call authoritarian
but what the Liberals insist on
is not only that you have to do what
they want you to do in public
you have to do it in private too you're
not allowed
to
be a conservative within the privacy of
your own home you're not allowed to
they encourage conservative rituals
within the privacy of your own home
they're going to shut down your churches
they're going to go they're going to go
send the FBI in to spy on your mass
they're going to send the FBI to go
knock on your door if you're a father of
seven but you're a pro-life Advocate and
you're a little too vocal they're going
to show up to your house
they're not they're going to if you
oppose the LGBT flag oh they're
that's going to be a problem you're not
going to get to wear a Gadsden flag
you're not going to get to maintain your
Traditions that's called totalitarianism
you're the the
authoritarianism is people talk about it
today in a very shallow way it's just
that there's a Bedrock set of rules that
people have to broadly respect in public
and then they can do whatever they want
totalitarianism is when the media when
the education system when the scientific
establishment when obviously the
bureaucracy and the institutions of the
government when all of that has to
uphold a very rigid ideological set of
views and if anyone breaks them it's
where members of the community it's
where members of the family are going to
be encouraged to rat on each other to
attack each other where you're going to
be sent into Thanksgiving dinner not to
have a nice holiday with your family but
to go lecture to go scold your
conservative Uncle for his backward
views on
global warming or whatever that's
totalitarianism and if those are the two
options
conservatives so so-called
authoritarianism
where we say hey clean up the streets
and act normal versus liberal
totalitarianism GO RAD on your uncle and
call up the feds if he seems a little
too conservative give me the
conservative version baby that's fine by
me
I think the chrysosons is uh very
steadily collapsing what a great clip
that was huh now make sure that you ring
the bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles Show podcast we'll see you next
time